parís 12 de diciembre de 2015 195 países
unen fuerzas para combatir el
calentamiento global pero en la
actualidad el planeta tiene poco para
celebrar 2020 está camino a convertirse
en el tercer año más cálido registrado
to put it simple y para hacerlo simple
nuestro planeta está quebrado queridos
amigos la humanidad está librando una
guerra contra la naturaleza
esto es suicida this is sweet side on
bajo el acuerdo climático de parís los
países acordaron limitar el
calentamiento global en 1.5 grados para
el final del siglo una meta que sigue
lejos de ser alcanzada por la mayoría
hasta el momento solo marruecos y gambia
están completando los objetivos esto
mientras el planeta ya se ha calentado
más de un grado desde 1900 y las
políticas actuales encaminar al mundo
hacia un aumento de temperatura de 3
grados muy lejos del objetivo inicial
a lo largo de la próxima década las
emisiones globales de co2 deberán
reducirse a la mitad para limitar el
calentamiento a 1.5 grados por ahora las
promesas a largo plazo aún no se han
traducido en acciones no sólo es
inconsistente es una brecha evidente
tiene que haber un aumento importante
entre lo que los gobiernos prometen
hacer y lo que realmente hacen para
tener alguna credibilidad ahora recordad
vaticinado pero hay un escenario más
optimista china asegura que alcanzar a
cero emisiones para 2060 japón corea del
sur y la unión europea aspiran a la
neutralidad de carbono para 2050 y todos
los ojos están puestos en hawai then
electo con una plataforma de
descarbonizar la economía de eeuu si
esas promesas se cumplen el
calentamiento global podría ser limitado
a 2.1 grados un paso crítico para evitar
las peores consecuencias del cambio
climático